hi I'm Erik Bosse and Godzilla king of
the monsters released a new trailer that
follows up its epic comic-con trailer
with lots of glorious new shots of kaiju
smashing and everything just like I do
to my apartment when the Wi-Fi drops out
just let me fight I'm gonna break this
trailer down shot by shot point out all
the details that you might have missed
including a few new possible monsters
revealed in some subtle moments Who am I
kidding
nothing about kaiju is subtle spoiler
warning in case any predictions into
being right and a special shout-out to
Luke Perry for being awesome during our
live countdown to our Avengers in-game
trailer breakdown premiere last weekend
thanks Luke let's get started hello
is anyone there
okay this trailer opens with Millie
Bobby Brown have stranger things Whitney
Bobby B who's playing Madison brussel
she's the daughter of Vera Farmiga
character dr. Emma Russel a paleo
biologist working for monarch the
organization from the previous movie
Madison's father is Mark Emma's
ex-husband played by Cal Chandler as
Madison tries to reach out to someone
with old radio equipment check out this
shot of the ocean here you can see
dozens of dead sea creatures floating on
the surface can't tell if those are
sharks or whales or just fish
perhaps they were killed by an electric
shock running through the water perhaps
caused by Ghidorah bursting out of the
Antarctic ice
there's also another shot of people
fleeing through Mexican streets as the
shadow of Rodin flies overhead and let's
move on to the next clip I'm trying to
reach
okay in this section we see a shot from
inside the cockpit of this large
aircraft this appears to be some kind of
mobile command center for the monarch
corporation so that they can track and
monitor the kaijus movements throughout
the world through the window we could
see the ruins of Washington DC the
Capitol dome the Washington Monument
tornadoes and lightning storms filled
the sky suggesting an attack from
Ghidorah you may be able to see some of
the serpent heads silhouetted in the
clouds now listen closely to the noises
that Madison hears from the radio
[Applause]
those could be sirens or it could be a
screech from a kaiju it actually sounds
a lot like the noise that Ghidorah makes
later in this trailer in my breakdown of
the last trailer I speculated that
Madison could have some kind of
telepathic link with Mothra and the
other kaiju
there's all those shots of her reaching
her hand out and her mother's research
involves trying to communicate with the
monsters with bioacoustics now in the
Toho movies there are those two twin
priestess fairies called the Shogun they
show up and they dance and they sing for
Mothra perhaps Madison's character could
be some version of that and maybe
accidentally tapping into the monsters
brain chemistry could explain Madison's
reaction here next clip senators we
believe that these titans are just the
tip of the iceberg okay here we see the
rise of Rodin from the volcano in Mexico
so cool followed by a helicopter landing
at the monster zero monarch station and
Antarctica then a new interesting shot
and oil field being torn up by the sharp
claws bursting from the ground now in
the last trailer we saw total of four
kaiju and I keep saying kaiju that's the
term of monsters they're also called
Titans I guess that's the term they're
using in this movie so those four are
Godzilla
returning to the first movie Mothra the
gentle giant Road and flying Pteranodon
and Ghidorah the ultimate nemesis the
evil one with these three serpent heads
they can create lightning storms but
when you go on the promotional website
for this movie monarch science is calm
you can see a number of other monarch
locations around the globe
with sightings and activity reported
from nearby areas and we've been told
that we will see somewhere between 10
and 15 total monsters in this movie now
one of these locations is in the South
Pacific
most likely Skull Island that's where
Kong is you can also track Godzilla's
current movement as of this recording
he's swimming in the South Atlantic
along South America toward Antarctica
now I'm not sure where this oil field is
maybe one of the two in the American
West or in the Middle East or in Sudan
or anima Rocco or Sicily but those
multiple legs make me think this could
be the kaiju ku Munga also known as
Spiga it's the spider
stur who first appeared in the Touhou
film son of Godzilla I'm not a huge fan
of spiders of any size so I really hope
it isn't this we also see quick shots of
Mark and the character played by Charles
dance Tywin Lannister from Game of
Thrones it sounds like he may be heading
up a mysterious other organization
that's in conflict with monarch there's
actually a theory going around that we
saw from a comment on our videos by Mike
Hawk saying that this guy could actually
be James Conrad that's Tom Hiddleston's
character in Kong Skull Island he was a
British Special Air Service captain he
served in Vietnam and throughout that
movie he gained a special appreciation
for kaiju and he would have a history of
hostility with monarch this movie's
director teased that one character from
Skull Island would appear in this movie
we also see Thomas Middleditch it's
character Sam Coleman he's a
communication liaison between monarch
and the government testifying before US
Senate panel he calls the Titans
discovered so far the tip of the iceberg
which could be a fun wordplay hinting at
the fact that Ghidorah is frozen deep
within polar ice and after a quick shot
of Sally Hawkins reprising her role as
dr. Vivian Graham from the previous
Godzilla movie we get the next clip
which of these titans are here to
protect us and which of these Titans are
here to threaten us okay lots going on
here after that monarch aircrafts in
fleet please read and there's this big
shockwave destroying a massive Hill in
this forest region this could be another
new kaiju with many thinking that it
could be an garrus garrus is a
quadrupedal monster with a spike covered
carapace and an elongated crocodile
style mouth it burrows under the ground
it can crawl and leap at fast speeds it
can actually jump backward to impale its
enemies on its spikes it first appeared
in SoHo film Godzilla raids again as a
rival to Godzilla but then later gained
a reputation as an allied to Godzilla
next to see a shot of these submarines
approaching as underwater cavern there's
a lava spilling out now this could be
Godzilla's undersea temple that's where
he goes to rest I think we'll you see
some more shots on this location later
then there's a quick shot from a battle
with some soldiers from the G team
that's a military unit that joins
monarch to fight kaiju situations and as
cool men asks if the monsters are here
to protect us the editing sinks a shot
of Mothra suggesting that this guide you
will keep its benevolent reputation in
this movie you can also hear some of its
sonic screech as it emits its God rays
and then a more destructive shot of
Raiden as Coleman says some of the
Titans are here to threaten us and
notice how that powerful gusts from its
wings lift people off the ground
yes alright let's move on
so you'd want to make Godzilla our pet
no we would be his ok this trailer
finally gives us our first close look of
Ghidorah crossing this Dunkin Donuts
sign as it crawls into Fenway Park in
Boston the size and the scale of this
thing are amazing you actually see the
texture on each of its spikes on its
massive tail as the rest of it moves in
the background I don't know if it's just
the rain of this shot but it reminds me
a lot of how the t-rex and drastic park
just knocked over parts of the fence
just because it was like too bulky and
awkward and then as the Senators laughs
and Coleman's face that the idea of
making Godzilla a pet Ken Watanabe
reprising his role as dr. Shiro Serizawa
gets in another great line don't fight
no once an IV come on we practiced this
it's it's we will be his pets it's gonna
be such a great my job let's try it
again
let who fight you already you know let's
just forget it let's move on
you're sure he's gonna be okay okay in
this section we see more of what it
looks like that undersea godzilla temple
maybe there's like an air pocket there
or something where there's the giant
sleeping kaiju and who assumed the
footage in the last trailer could be
Serizawa approaching him to make him so
that he can hit the monsters against
each other and actually do you one take
this one watanabe leave with bees then
as we see godzilla scare mark and dr.
Chynn then the submarine blast past them
can actually see the shockwave from his
atomic breath rippling through the water
then there's some more shots of Madison
and Emma actually sounds like they've
been kidnapped
perhaps by Charles dances mysterious
organization and then there's a quick
shot of Ghidorah laying waste and we
move on battling for dominance
arrival outfit to go to you've got a big
kid okay here dr. Graham confirms that
several kaiju are popping up everywhere
across the globe with some of them
pairing off to fight there's a shot of
Rodin reaching out to snatch the monarch
aircraft and a shot of Mothra swooping
in with her claws out perhaps we'll see
an aerial dogfight between these two
flyers and then a very interesting wide
shot of Godzilla Ghidorah facing off the
size of goo doors wingspan is just
insane
then there's the shot of Barnes that's
the leader of the G team played by
O'Shea Jackson jr. fighting in that
snowy and article battle perhaps this is
a moment Ghidorah rises from the ice and
a shot of Ghidorah firing lightning out
of its mouth you can actually see the
electric charge building up in its neck
kind of like this is lightning vomit
next clip
okay here there's another close-up of
Mothra as it screeches and dives at a
battle is also a shot of this massive
creature on fire it's caused a nearby
structures to suddenly burst into flames
now this could be an adaptation of fire
Godzilla
that's a fiery version of the kaiju that
I actually just have a toy of so maybe
that's why I'm seeing it and then
there's a lot more battle shots
including Ronin
taking out a nearby aircraft with a
barrel roll you notice how the clouds in
front of it illuminate with that yellow
electricity this could be once again
from Ghidorah this might be taking place
over that big DC battle let's move on to
the final clip
whoo yeah Millie Bobby B said the best
Oh Shh
indeed Godzilla and Ghidorah slam into
each other in Boston and you know not to
fat shame a kaiju but it's pretty
impressive to see something with
Godzilla's curves move that fast Fenway
Park's quickest heavyweight waddles
since the days of Big Papi this shot
reminds me of the way the trailer for
Thor Ragnarok ended remember it cuts to
the title right before the collision and
we actually look at the frame right
before that title reveal you could see
how Godzilla's playing some smart
defense here uses each of his claws to
grab Ghidorah left and right head clamp
the mouth shut while he uses his mouth
to dive in toward the center neck will
it be very effective we'll see my
question for you is which of these kaiju
would you be most terrified up like a
door it seems like the most threatening
but if the spider thing is in this movie
I will have to go back to lining my
sheets just kidding
I never stopped lining up comment down
below with your nightmare kaiju and
follow new rock stars on Twitter at new
rock stars follow me on twitter and
instagram at boss and subscribe to new
rock stars or breakdowns of all the cool
new trailers that we're excited about
and up just something about spiders
again got a change
[Music]